- I think Canadian candy tastes nicer.
Tastes more polite.
- Because the people are more polite?
- Yeah.
- That's a sweeping stereotype.
("Well Lit")
- [Man] Woah!
- [Woman] Ooh!
- Woah, it's huge.
- Can you not get enough
crisp in your crunch?
- Is it made of moose?
- [Both] Cheers.
- I did not know that you
could have too much crunch,
but that's what that is.
- It tastes a little bit more
natural than a Butterfinger.
- I'm gonna say it's better.
- It sticks to your teeth so much.
- I would not buy this.
- [Voiceover] Wunderbar!
- I read it as Wunderbra.
- A peanut butter caramel experience.
- This isn't a candy,
this is an experience.
- Look at that, yeah.
- It has a weird texture.
- Too stringy for me.
- I like it.
- I can't even finish swallowing this.
- It's like your friend
that won't let go of you.
- Wunderbar, I wonder why
they didn't make that (beep)
easier to eat, am I right?
- I like it.
- [Voicever] Coffee Crisp.
- They're very literal with their names.
- This is a graham cracker
with chocolate. That's it.
- Ooh. Ooh! Ooh!
- Ooh. This is a nice one.
- This is my perfect candy.
It is a coffee-flavored,
wafer crisp chocolate bar.
I'm in (beep) Heaven right now.
- Oh, is there coffee in here? Uh uh, no.
- I do not get the coffee flavor at all.
- It melts in your mouth and
it's crunchy at the same time.
- I would eat these like crazy
if they were available to me.
- [Both] Ooh!
- They are cute!
- This is their leaf.
- Oh, it smells mapley.
- My God, that is strong.
- Too much is going on in my mouth.
I kinda like it, though.
- This is definitely the best one so far.
- I like it.
- I like that.
- I feel like I've eaten a candle.
- These are amazing.
- I've never had anything like this.
- So flavorful.
- Is this another form
of currency in Canada,
because I could see that.
- Everything was good,
but I think I'm gonna stick
to my American chocolate.
- Canadian candy wins by far.
- I'd have to say American candy
only for nostalgia reasons.
- Coffee Crisp is like a revelation,
and I don't know why it's not in America.
- Canadian candy has impressed
me on the chocolate front.
I gotta see how they
do gummy worms, though.
- I assume that America,
we got candy figured out.
Turns out there's a whole
bunch of candy out there
that's really good that we don't have.